the big man himself sean hannity joins
me now what
pete what big man you know
no by the way i like the role reversal i
kind of like it you know
it's your time to be the ground for the
hannity show now he's hosting
by the way i watched her coverage last
night with jillian and lisa booth that
was phenomenal
um congratulations you're a dear friend
of mine
lj great to have you in the spot and uh
i watched your commentary last night and
i watched it tonight and what you're
saying is
yeah it's that bad and it's going to get
worse
you hit on one point the one issue all
these
high paying career jobs in the energy
sector
these are jobs that are paying six
figures highly skilled jobs
pink slips go out with well we want you
to get another union job uh
that'll pay well okay well we've got 17
million americans out of work
we're taking in between 11 and 15
million
with the new biden amnesty program and
more coming every day
uh all all these people at once are
going to be simultaneously competing for
any job that opens up lj
and what's interesting to me is like
they don't seem to care
because we know what happens when it's
supply and demand and it crisscrosses
that will dictate lower wages for
working americans
and that's going to hurt the country
then you add to that
okay the lifeblood of of the world's
economy is oil
gas energy and wind turbines didn't
particularly work that well down in
texas when we needed them
uh where you're from and i'll tell you
it's uh it's a little frightening now
that the price oil
is going up at the pump heating our
homes is going to cost more
cooling our homes is going to cost more
then it's going to be another 2 trillion
dollars for the new green deal
most of this money people sean say they
didn't know about this
uh we covered that fox you sent me all
across the country talking with voters
you did a great job thank you i guess i
guess you won't talk to me in a year i
know go ahead
the other people you know on the other
networks
they didn't know this was gonna happen i
see people breaking down on tv all the
time talking about
how this has impacted them do you think
the media
failed the american public by being so
in the tank for joe biden
look there's a great disservice if you
look at last week alone
you showed joe biden over the weekend uh
uh
what what the hell am i doing here uh
i'm getting lost
the week that last week in the course of
a week remember he said
he got lost he lost his trend of thought
and he reached it i i carried these
cards and the only number he was looking
for
was the total number of americans which
is way too high it's the worst pandemic
since 1917 and 18 and we lost 500 000
of our fellow americans not a hard
number to remember
and he's like i got it written here
somewhere and i'm like
well what's on the card my name is joe
my wife's name is jill i live at 1600
pennsylvania avenue
um you know we choose truth over facts
you know the the governor the mormon guy
um
you know endowed by the oh you know the
thing the thing
you know god the creator of everything
and it's getting a little scary it's
funny because the media was attacking me
for
for saying that joe looks weak and he
looks frail
and he's struggling cognitively well
every day now pretty much when he speaks
when he's allowed to speak
he's struggling something's going on
here lj and it's beginning
who's running things sean who do you
think is the person that has the ear of
the president
look um another story that went
unreported or
underreported let's say is kamala harris
you know
directly talking to the leaders of
foreign countries
now there might be some of that but not
with the new administration i would
expect the president the
commander-in-chief
to be leading our foreign policy and
right now i'm not exactly sure that
joe biden is in he look here's what i
ask everybody to do don't take sean
hannity's word for it
go back and google or yahoo
joe biden's name look up some videos
look of him
tapes of him 10 years ago look at tapes
of him from four years ago when he left
office
to me it's it's very obvious i'm not a
doctor i'm not playing one on
on television or radio i want the best
for our country though
and i want a president that's fully
completely engaged and
uh it's now becoming worth some to me
and i'm one of the few people that seem
i guess dumb enough or courageous enough
to talk about it yeah
i'm no doctor either sean but i know
that he was once known as the
greatest retail politician and they kept
in the basement i know because i was at
his house reporting there
to see if he was going to come out and
speak to us but we got to give it a
little bit
the president of united former president
of the united states spoke at cpac
yesterday
he outlined his case of what went wrong
but there was this optimistic approach
for the future he said
listen i know a lot of people are saying
that the republican party is split
he said that would be dumb i'm not
starting a new party
i'm moving forward was that the right
tone and message
i think it was the perfect toner message
and and he did something else
i i saw a pivot as it relates to the
election
and what he rightly said is we we can't
have elections that last
in perpetuity we should have an election
day with absentee
ballot considerations there are
conditions
you know my argument post-election was
always well
the law the statutory language and the
law says
partisan observers should observe they
should be able to observe
the consent agreement in georgia i think
that should have been one standard for
signature verification
if the state constitution of
pennsylvania
has very limited options for mail-in
balloting
i don't think the legislature legally
has the right to then over
just bypass their own constitution a 4-3
close decision in wisconsin on the issue
of mail-in balloting
i think every republican legislature now
needs
to fix these problems but then he went
and he did something that i think is
very important
and that is where is the conservative
movement i'm a registered conservative
you're more you lean more libertarian
although i share some of your
libertarianism
on a lot of issues but conservatism is
simple
lj it's really easy we believe in
liberty we believe in freedom
we believe in lower taxes limited
government
less bureaucracy so we can we can
unleash
entrepreneurialism in this country we
want constitutionalists on the bench
we want secure borders uh we want energy
independence and all the high-paying
jobs that go along with it
uh it would be nice if we had law and
order in and safety and security
security in every town and city it would
be great if we could fix our public
school system
and give parents choice in school they
got to open up the school
sean they got to open it up they got it
the science
we were told that the sign says that
it's safe for the kids to go back to
school
all of a sudden the talking points have
changed and there's been no
accountability
on this issue it makes me furious
because the people that i saw that case
where the guy out in california
you know the i guess it was uh one of
the representatives of the unions
yeah he's advocating keep schools closed
his kids go to a private school that's
open right
uh very typical look and if you add
peace through strength and you add free
and fair trade
that's it lawrence lj that's
conservatism
it's not complicated and here's the best
part of why i'm a conservative
and what the president laid out
yesterday his policies
worked we he shattered record after
record low unemployment for every
demographic group
in this country african-americans
hispanic americans asian-americans
women in the workplace youth
unemployment for the first time in 75
years we were energy independent
he unleashed america's military and they
took out solomonie they took out the
caliphate they took out baghdadi
and they took out the al-qaeda leader in
yemen guess what
our policies work america becomes
prosperous
every single time conservatism is tried
here's the last thought
this new green deal socialism socialism
throughout history i have a chapter in
my last book
socialism it's history of failure i
don't care what name it takes
what manifestation it is in new green
deal in this case
it always results in the same thing
failed and broken and unfulfilled
promises
more poverty and yes loss of freedom
but then it's a matter of how much
another the degree of freedoms that are
lost
in the name of security sean hannity
folks you're so lucky because
on a 7 p.m show you just got a preview
of what you're going to have
on the 9pm show all right so i got to
tell the audience one thing before we go
so lj and i are very close friends yeah
and i'm really proud of you i was
watching uh your coverage
last night with jillian and lisa booth
was phenomenal
um you're doing great work and i'm just
hoping in a year or two you'll still
talk to me i'm hoping no no you're my
brother i appreciate you son i see you
tonight
i'll see you tonight my friend god bless
sean hannity folks